Houston Howard, Transmedia Author/Speaker:
So I think the new business model for
creators is a business model to attack the
market with IP attack the market with IP.
Film Courage: What is the business
model for filmmakers today?
Houston: The business model for filmmakers
today is it's a complicated question
because the question could be what should be
the the business model for filmmakers today
but but what is the the the model for
filmmakers today I think still sits
wholly in that traditional model of I
got to go to the studio and I got to
you know option my option my script and go through
the development process and and go through that
whole thing there's the whole traditional side
of the business that's still moving along but now
on the outside of the studio system then you're
you're looking at a different business model
that is is more IP [intellectual property] focused
and I think if you if you really study the market
and understand the way the market works it's about
how do you launch and grow IP and and and this is
this is not a new concept because we've known
for decades that everything that we see on tv
is always based on a book and even the the stuff
that we know is the most original we think is
the most original stuff we've ever we've ever uh
considered and we we love the originality of this
limited series or this interesting film 98 of the
time you trace it back and it's based on a book
and the reason it's based on a book isn't because
hollywood's in love with books it's because they
love the pre-awareness that the books bring they
love the community that's already built for the
book and it skews the risk analysis into the favor
of the filmmaker when they say hey let's let's
take this book and let's make it a movie it's just
a lower risk investment and so so so IP creation
and establishing IP in the market is has has
always been a thing and but now in the with the
proliferation of other platforms and the the the
democratization of other platforms where normal
people can have access to these other platforms
such as podcast and Webtoon and what short stories
on Wattpad comic books things like that now the
business model for creators is how to take their
IP and attack the market in whatever platform they
can so that they could establish a market presence
grow the community of that around that IP actually
get fans and then once they have fans then maybe
down the road they go and shop this thing for
for film and television because when you do that
you can actually have a conversation because you
you have something established in the market and
you have fans and you've established pre-awareness
and I think pre-awareness is is is vital in in
today's market because of the high risk economics
of of filmmaking because the p a budgets because
the budge the the production budgets are are just
increasing so much I mean you look at you look at
the lord of the rings series on amazon they spent
250 million dollars just for the rights and then
they spent 450 million dollars in production
for one season of tv and so you're spending
three quarters of a billion dollars on a season
of television and so they're not going to do that
with something that hasn't been established in
the market the only reason they're comfortable
with with spending three quarters of a
billion dollars is because lord of the rings
is an established IP in the market and that and
there's a legion of tolkien fans and and they've
tested the the previous the hobbit movies and
lord of the rings movies and and it's been around
for a zillion years and all of a sudden it skews
the risk analysis into the favor of the studio
they said I think we can do it I mean you look
at the foundation series that's coming out on on
apple that apple's releasing and that that that
was a series of books that's been around forever
and and a lot of people maybe won't know that and
think oh this is just original filmmaking no it's
established i.p in the market but but used to you
could the only way you could do that is through a
book but now like I said you can you can do that
in a variety of different ways and so one of the
most option things in Hollywood right now are
podcasts podcasts are wildly popular as far as
being optioned and you look at what amazon did
with homecoming not Beyonce homecoming but the
other homecoming with Julia Roberts the the the
drama series and that was a podcast you look at
something like night fail there was a podcast
you look at what HBO max they they greenlit the
Calm app tv show I don't know if anybody you're
familiar with the com app the comm app's been a
top 10 app in the app store for the last 10 years
the meditation app it's just a meditation app for
that promotes the proposed mental health and keeps
makes you calm and helps you meditate and HBO max
just green lit a tv show based on the app which
makes no sense other than there's a brand there
and there's a community there and there's
pre-awareness in the market they'll hire a writer
and they'll hire producers and they'll hire talent
that'll make it work but what they were looking
for is is there the pre-awareness in the market
and you see something with angry birds angry
birds launched into the market not as the animated
films launched in the market as a mobile game and
so I think that is the new business model for
creators is how do I how do I not wait for Netflix
or amazon or universal pictures or Disney to to
give me permission to make my dreams come true
I don't I don't want to wait for Netflix to
give me permission to tell the story that's
in my heart it it it you'll be waiting forever
right and and and you'll be deceived by the fact
that there are some people that Netflix does come
and make their dreams come true and they give them
the big giant check but but for every one person
that's waiting for that that it actually works for
there's there's a hundred thousand people hundred
thousand filmmakers that that never get that break
and it's not because they're less talented
it's just because it's a it's a hard
industry and it's competitive and there's
a lot of super talented people out there
and it's tough to be able and and the line around
Netflix is 10 blocks long figuratively speaking
with people that want to get in Netflix right so
so it's it people are waiting for these studios
to give them permission to to follow
their heart and tell their story
when I say that's that's cool but don't wait or
at least while you're waiting attack the market
while you're waiting launch your IP in the 10
or 15 or 20 ways that we have at your fingertips
at all time that you can do for very little or
zero money like a podcast you can you can take
you can take your iPhone and you can download
anchor an anchor is is a free app on the app store
that will allow you to hold up the phone to your
ear and it records your podcast in just into the
phone and then it distr and you put bumper music
and you can edit it and then it distributes it
into the the apple podcast store and it puts
it on Spotify all completely for free and then
you can use the the distribution platforms and
social media and things like that to to get it
in front of people start building your audience
and you can actually tell the story that you intel
while you're waiting on Netflix but the trick is
then if you actually grow the community of people
that that love your podcast love your story and
and are engaging with your brand you've increased
your chances from hearing from Netflix because
you've actually created pre-awareness the market
right and you you accelerate I mean I there
was there was a there was an IP that I had
uh we we we sold we sold to fox it languished in
development when the turnaround we got it back
and we had played that game for seven years
trying to shop it finally got it shopped
wanted to turn around got it back seven years
and I thought what would have happened if I
would we would have been running a podcast the
entire time what would have been what would have
happened if I would we would have had comic books
in the market and release self-published novels
into the market we wouldn't when it goes in the
turnaround we wouldn't be at zero again we would
have had fans and we would have had a brand and
we would have had IP the film and television
wouldn't have worked the way we wanted it to work
and then we'd have to kind of reorganize that
but at least we would have done some
other things and attack the market
in a way and and not just wait for a giant studio
to give me a giant Ed McMahon check and say I give
you permission to tell the story that you've
always wanted to tell and it's so so I'm very
very bullish on encouraging
filmmakers don't wait launch
launch launch use all the stuff that we have all
the tools in the toolbox to launch the IP if if
people that can produce music work with them to
maybe tell a story through a song and launch that
if how to write a short story launch launch that
if how to do a podcast do it that way do a web
tune do do do something and one it it helps you
not be frustrated as you wait to hear back from
an agent and send it out query letters
and the whole game that we all know
which is I'm not saying that's bad I'm saying okay
let's do that but while we do that let's do some
other things so you're not just sitting around
waiting to hear back from people you're actually
doing something right which keeps you it just
keeps you happy as a storyteller to be able
to tell your stories I mean I personally I found
myself years ago as a writer the thing the things
that I wrote most were pitch decks I found
myself writing more pitch decks than I were
that I did scripts and that was disconcerting to
me right because that's sort of what you kind of
fall into in Hollywood is this crazy game of just
trying to like hustle something and and and you're
doing a lot less creating and just a lot more
pitching right and so so there's there's a I
think there's an artistic and a soulful benefit
to launching IP in the market just satisfies
you as you wait for the the big guys to come and
make your dreams come true but then there's also
a legal benefit to it and so I consider myself a
recovering lawyer I started my career as a lawyer
and almost completely recovered as a lawyer but
from a legal perspective if if you can establish
an IP in the market there's a lot greater chance
of you getting a better deal on the back end if
and when the studio comes and wants to participate
in into a feature film if you just write a spec
script and you go and like like like filmmakers
do and like writers do and you go sell that spec
script and it's not based on any pre-existing IP
it's it's just an original idea and you sell you
settle inspect say you get on the black list and
and they snatch it off the black list and they
they they give you a deal that's awesome it's it's
it's by and large a wholesale acquisition it's
we're taking the whole bucket of rights and we'll
give you a check that's a high five handoff that
you you go off and we'll take this and we'll
go and make this movie but they have all the
rights to every platform ever created and here
forever two will be created until the end of time
there's all those big lawyerly clauses in there
they own everything right they take the whole deal
theoretically they give you a check to make you
feel better about that right which sometimes that
makes you feel better other times it doesn't but
if you say publish a book self-publish a book and
and and that book sells and you're able to then
get that to be turned into a movie the deal that
is then done is a different deal it's then you
have what's called a split rights deal where they
come and license the right to adapt the book into
a movie right so they take the film and television
rights right but it's a license deal for the film
and television rights and you maintain your other
IP rights video game comic books merchant things
like other things that you want to create right
and which is much better in success of the movie
right or the tv show or whatever they do then all
these other rights become more valuable and
you've retained them simply because you were
able to establish the IP in the market and you
didn't you didn't go to the studios first right so
so even if you don't want to talk about
the the sort of the creative benefits of
attacking the market and being aggressive with
the IP and not waiting right and being passive
as as your fake lawyer as for that that I would
give you this this legal advice never just sell
a spectrum to a studio it's crazy just publish it
self-publish it as a book first now ten years ago
before you could really self-publish or there
wasn't really podcast and there weren't really
these other things then what are you supposed
to do the only thing you could do is is just
sell it directly to a studio because not not a
lot of other other options right now there are
so many options it's it makes it just doesn't make
a lot of sense to be able to go to them first you
just you're just you're misappropriated and losing
sight of the broader opportunity of your IP so so
I think the new business model for creators is a
business model to attack the market with IP attack
the market with IP and when you when you generate
the pre-awareness of the community it's going to
create residual benefits that is that are not only
going to make you more attractive to the studios
but it's actually going to help you retain more
and control more of the IP moving forward and from
what I understand about this new Netflix series
made yeah with Margaret Qualley it it started
as an article [on Vox] a woman [Stephanie Land]
who was in a homeless shelter with her child she
was cleaning houses and she kind of wrote this
thing about hey what people don't know about
what I know about you from cleaning your house
and that took off and then she did this book
yeah and then and now and now we have this this
show coming up sure I'm looking forward to seeing
it and again that was someone that was always
wanted to be a writer had a lot of tragic things
happen and decided to hunker down and sort of make
the best of it and look at now it's sure that's a
rags to riches story right there and if she would
have just written that as a spec script and then
just started shopping that around I think we we
would well we wouldn't be having this conversation
today because because it would have gotten it
would be languishing in the crazy game that is
the spec world of Hollywood right she she was able
to take this and then launch it in a different way
let's write the article let's let's do it let's
launch it in a different form let's then publish
the book let's let's do it as a blog let's
do something else right and and then we we
grow awareness we grow the pre-awareness we we've
we've actually established the IP in the market
and then guess what especially when it becomes
popular then then then the studios want to get
involved and that deal and I'm not privy
to the the specifics of the deal but but
I would guarantee that that deal that was
made for that particular that particular IP
is a better deal than she would have got if she
would have written the spec script and tried to
sell that spectre at first I don't think she
would have sold the spec grip to begin with
but in the event that she would have it would
have been a worse deal than what she got now
simply because she was able to establish it
in the market right but see see this is the
interesting thing it's a paradigm shift
with with filmmakers typically filmmakers
and and and screenwriters and listen I include
myself in this umbrella so it we we we want to
focus on filmmaking and screenwriting and and and
we feel like if I just write my five pages a day
everything's gonna work and I don't wanna learn
how to do a podcast like that's not me I don't
wanna learn how to make a website I don't
wanna I don't wanna uh write short stories
I'm a screenwriter right and and I
wish I wish that person would have been
born in 1978 and then was able to be able
to operate in late 80s 90s Hollywood because
because it was just as a different market
and you could kind of specialize like that
but but but it's just it's a different market
and and there's this this there's this hesitancy
for lack of a better word if if I say that
euphemistically there's this hesitancy to
broaden your scope of creative to be able
to launch an IP in the market you feel like
you're you're doing something that's less than
screenwriting you're lowering yourself to do a
short story you're lowering yourself to do a
podcast there's this this this this artistic
judgment and you feel like you you and maybe you
just judge yourself of like man that this means
that I'm if I was good enough i'd be able to sell
this thing right and and you judge yourself for
it and and you shouldn't judge yourself for that
you it's it's there's too much stuff out there
and it's way too competitive and I think if if if
creators and filmmakers and screenwriters if they
have the mind of a of an entrepreneur who's who's
launching a consumer brand you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna approach this whole thing
differently because you talk to any entrepreneur
that that says I'm gonna start a pizza shop right
and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna open the pizza
shop and and it's gonna be great because I have
this family recipe of pizza i've been working on
like they are forced to learn a hundred new
skills in order to launch that pizza shop
right you never hear somebody say I want to launch
my pizza shop with my family recipe of pizza and
I'm only going to focus on making the pizza
I'm not going to learn how to do payroll I'm
not going to learn how to hire front of house
back house I'm not going to learn how to order
I'm not going to learn about management I'm
not going to learn how to do the register
I'm not going to learn about anything else
other than pizza and that's it I'm just going
to focus on my pizza and as long as I make
good pizza everything will fall into place
odds are that pizza shop will never open right
because of course entrepreneurs know I want to
do a pizza shop I know how to make a good pizza
okay I still have to learn how to run the register
and I still have to learn how to market the
right way and I still have to learn how to
how how to manage my staff and I still
have to learn how to order all the food
from the wholesalers and things like that you it
you're forced into figuring out five or six new
things that you've never figured out before and
that's just part of being an entrepreneur and
every entrepreneur will tell you that like you
have to you're forced to learn 100 new things
what are those 10 new things that we need to learn
as screenwriters and filmmakers what are the 20
new things that that that we can learn as creators
that can help us launch the IP and and here's the
good part here's the here's the punch line that
I think is the greatest punch line of all time
it's all there on the internet for free
youtube is the greatest educational platform
in the history of mankind if I want to figure
out how to change a 1987 Volvo station wagons
carburetor there's probably a Youtube video
that's going to walk me through it we can
go to go to Youtube go to Google and say how do I
how do I create a podcast and there's 17 articles
instantly or 17 videos that pop up you can go
to Linkedin learning and and or or you can go to
whatever like resource that you want to use
and you can take the 7 to 10 to 27 hours
to figure it out and not that you can connect with
people that know how to do it I had a buddy who
he won the Nicholl Fellowship as a screenwriter
right which is a big deal Nicholl Fellowship is
a very competitive screenwriting competition he
won the Nicholl Fellowship he he pitched a movie
to Paramount Pictures as a result of winning
the Nicholl Fellowship he pitched the script
to Paramount. Paramount said it was too risky
because it wasn't established in the marketplace
and they said we want you to go and create a comic
book and launch it as a comic book and if you sell
10 000 copies of that comic book come
back to us and we'll make your movie
so he walked out of that meeting super bummed
not just because they didn't make the movie but
they said make a comic book and guess what he was
a screenwriter he didn't know how to make a comic
book right which if this was 1992 that would have
been a big bummer but because it was 2017 he was
able to go home open up the laptop google how do
I make a comic book and you started reading and
he started finding out where the artist hung out
online and the artist communities and Art Station
and Deviantart and things like that he he learned
the production workflow the cost of making a comic
book how they were distributed he just started
researching and he connected with an artist
in a like Estonia or some Eastern European country
that that that he they decided to collaborate on
something they they scraped and put one issue of
a comic book together took them months they put
an issue of one issue of a comic together and
they they distributed it digitally on amazon
and made enough money from it to make an issue too
and then they made enough money on it to make an
issue three and then they made enough money on it
to make it issue four and then after issue four
guess what happened they got picked up by a small
independent publisher that said we'll pay for the
publishing of it right so they did issue five
and then after issue five they're putting it
all together as a trade paperback all five issues
together and now four years later he's right on
the verge of his 10 000 unit cell right and he
says Houston guess what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
go back to paramount pictures and tell them to
make my movie because I have to hit the ten 10 000
or the 10 000 sale mark right but guess what
I'm not going to stop selling my comic book
why because it's an extra source of revenue for
me and I have a community of fans that love this
stuff right so why would I stop and so now he
self-identifies as not just a screenwriter but
he's a screenwriter slash comic book creator
right he's there's there's this there's this
this term called polymath right people that are
good at multiple things and we typically lawed
people in entertainment that can do more right
Beyonce can sing and she can dance and J Lo can
act and sing and dance and and we always say all
these people are amazing they're entrepreneurs
and actors and singers and creators and and we
love that about people we need to start looking
at ourselves as that because we have the ability
to do that and because all the tools are in front
of us so I think that's the model that we have to
hit is is being willing to have that mindset shift
of I need to learn some more I need to broaden
my own skill set right and but when I do it's
going to open up a no new world for me because
I'm able to establish my IP in the market.
Do you agree with Houston? What
are you doing to attack the market?